revealing last night another clark
county school district student died by
suicide
the latest death since the start of the
school year 8 news now reporter kristen
drummond shows us the rising concerns
as the pandemic continues to affect more
children and teenagers
it's really sad an 11 year old child to
see these kind of behaviors
josh curtis notices a difference with
his oldest son braxton
he's at the point now where he just
doesn't care a recent shift in behavior
for the normally active sixth grader
he was in sports he's in dance as a star
student previously and accelerated
classes and now
he's just not going to class and he just
doesn't care curtis attributes the
change to the pandemic
and distance education he doesn't even
tell his friends he's depressed every
day
any change of behavior is a warning sign
health experts are seeing similar
situations
it causes concern as suicides continue
happening
this school year we've had before
deaths involving suicide amongst our
clark county school district students so
that's been
very very difficult dr sheldon jacobs
with the southern nevada chapter of the
national alliance on mental illness says
there is a mental health crisis in our
community along with suicides
psychiatric hospitalizations are also
rising among children
a result of our current circumstances
you need to
you know be more isolated um you know
working with friends
not we are seeing increasingly
more incidents of suicide attempts and
completions from
from kids younger than 12. curtis tells
me he's talking with his son
and even considering counseling we're
trying what we can and
you know i'm not sure what at this point
we're kind of at a loss but not giving
up at trying to improve his son's mental
health
kristen drummond 8 news now the nevada
coalition for suicide prevention says
suicide is the leading cause of death
for teenagers
ages 12 to 19 in our state we do have a
list of mental health resources
available for parents on our website for
you
at 8newsnow.com